so far so good yes ladies and gentlemen
I'm very thrilled to be here tonight in
such a great occasion
Spain start winning the evening and now
I'm in a company of such a gifted and
beautiful lady of you thank you so much
thank you now in this little part that
we have now we were given the most
beautiful and really funny material to
do with lots of great jokes but we're
just going to get on with it what I see
is not for God they were real good
though okay it's well I think well now
you well let's go to business really
alright meanwhile the men nominated for
original scores this year are
[Music]
john williams for et the
extra-terrestrial Ravi Shankar and
George Fenton for Gandhi
[Applause]
Jack natira officer in jail
[Applause]
jerry goldsmith for polar guys
and Marvin Hamlisch for Sophie's Choice
John Williams 42
thank you I feel very lucky to have been
asked by Steven Spielberg to compose a
score for this very optimistic and
loving and beautiful film and I would
like to thank the orchestra here in
Hollywood that contributed mightily to
this soundtrack and for me this is a
particular joy thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]